[Music]
seven seasons in the National Football
League was all that was sufficient for
this man to make the Pro Football Hall
of Fame win two Super Bowls a Super Bowl
MVP and being the all-time single
leading real time leading rusher in the
history of the Denver Broncos he is
Terrell Davis how are you what's up rich
how you doing this morning I'm doing
well we got some news this morning
doubly juicy news this morning I
remember waking up seeing a little text
coming there and Antonio Brown is at it
again well mike Mayock has spoken I will
give you a choice the over-under is
twelve point five seconds that's how
long his statement was you take the over
the under I'm going under okay under
here we go Terrell Davis you're a winner
yeah we knew that already
I know Mike here was oh no it was 15
seconds teen oh gosh oh man here we go
let's check it out okay short and sweet
Antonio Brown's not in the building
today you won't be practicing I don't
have any more information for you right
now and when I have some and it becomes
appropriate you guys all get it I
promise you but that's it for today
there you go thank you it's not in the
building today that means he's not
playing Monday right he's definitely
playing Monday no I I mean from what I'm
hearing and reading and watching and
then seeing uh he will not be playing
against the Broncos on Monday Night
Football which you got to be happy about
that well I'm sure if you're a Broncos
fan absolutely I mean yeah right yeah
you know the deal with Antonio Brown
absolutely but I mean here's I mean for
but it's bigger than that to me it's not
about just Denver this is an unfortunate
situation for a guy who was one of the
best in the business and to go about his
business the way he's been the last what
year now it's just why the questions why
why do you have to do things like this
you know you have Pittsburgh you didn't
like it there you you basically push
forced your way out of there you go to
Oakland and it's and where they where
they will be hailed yeah it willing to
pay you the money that you wanted to be
paid you go there and before the season
even starts you have the footy issue
which okay I'll give you that one
you know you that's just trying to get
better trying to you know get your legs
back
frostbite has bite it well that's right
that's that's a new that's a new great a
bumper sticker frostbite happens but no
I like that but to me that wasn't like
um a decision that you refused to show
up for something that's team related
right okay you did that that was it was
stupid but it was an intentional maybe
he did want to maybe he didn't on
purpose not to go to training camp I
don't know but then you talk about the
helmet issue that to me was was like all
right we get a helmet until you win your
grievance with the helmets that you
wanted what that you want to wear go to
practice with your teammates you know
you seemed healthy we're out there
running once you see that did it's like
that's a big issue it's affecting your
teammates you can't prepare for the game
everybody has to answer questions about
you every single day that's when the
word disruptive starts to come in that's
what you don't need as a team you know
the good teams don't have players who
are just about themselves and just care
about the attention they receive so that
was a problem and then you get this
thing where he gets fine which I'm glad
he got fined that's the way it's
supposed to work it's supposed to work
where a player doesn't show up a player
comes to a meeting late
you're supposed to be fined no matter
who you are where there is a star or
second-year player but why do you think
he views it is an affront to him no I
don't know did you ever have a player
that viewed for being a fine is a
personal affront give her have a
teammate no thank God I didn't know I
mean I played with I played great
players Shannon Sharpe John Elway Steve
Atwater you know you play with Rod Smith
you know we played all these great
players and the one thing that I
appreciated now looking back on it we
had players that could have abused their
power John could have easily abused his
power not knocked up in meetings you
know showed up late because he's the two
cuz he's because he's a John Elway but
he never did that and which me seeing it
I mocked I kind of modern my
my leadership after Jaws when I saw him
not doing that when Shannon was coming
at every meeting wouldn't show up late
didn't abuse you know taking days off
when it's in the building in his culture
it's a cultural thing it allows the
young players to see that and to sort of
mimic that 1:8 when they get in that
position and so no I never he never had
a guy like that that we had to deal with
who just became about his attention so
then what about Terrell Davis here in
the Rich Eisen show what about on
somebody else's team or another spot
have you ever heard of a physical
altercation between player and and
management when the when management came
up to talk or player goes up to
management that that's fine that's
physical okay not physical I've heard of
you know shouting matches and but that's
that wearing those were in were those in
winning locker rooms well yeah that part
is that part is the the human element
and s emotions and that's okay if it's a
one you know one off something happens a
lot of times even in winning locker
rooms you'll have players who have a
disagreement with even a head coach GM
the owner and it happens and you'll have
that one you know one or two players but
that's this is coming on the heels of
everything else has already happened yes
cuz again I think you you see you know
you're a smart man Terrell Davis you see
where I'm driving at here is about the
next yeah like how much of an outlier is
something like this how how can it be
put back together do you think based on
again we're sitting here reading tweets
hearing about things from the outside
just knowing you're the inside as well
as you do and have how can something
with everything that's gone down be put
back together where Mayock feels that
he's managed generally imagining this
team Gruden is coaching it they've set a
standard which may octa bout which is
why so many people were like scratching
edge why would you go take somebody's
problem right unless it was unless
everybody thought as soon as he gets
paid it's that's always that's all he's
acting out about it's just payment but
clearly it's something else is at
take whether it's the way you view him
in terms of respect or I don't know what
it is the question is how can this be
put back together in your estimation I
said this when they traded for Antonio
Brown I said that I've never seen a
situation workout where a guy who acted
like Antonio Brown forces his way out
all the things we heard about missing
the meetings the Facebook live in the
locker room all that stuff that was
going there changes that once they go to
a new location especially when you
basically be reward him I mean he's
looking at like okay I forced my way out
of here here and I got what I wanted why
would I change you knew I was coming to
meetings late in Pittsburgh you know I
was I was missing meetings you know I
was showing out when I wanted to show up
what would make him change that when you
just paid this Fadem and then paid him
that money what he was looking for in
Pittsburgh why would you think that
would change I have never seen a workout
where that kind of behavior from a
goddess that's doing that then go
somewhere else and all of a sudden it
just you know people say New England is
kind of at that place and it said well
if he went to New England he'd change
and honestly I don't I don't know if
that I'll agree with that
Urlacher joked about that too yeah I
don't know if I were that and how other
people go there oh I don't know fella
check with Brennan exactly
so I've never seen it and by the way
you're right and the streak is
continuing of it never was it seems to
be a total disaster right now he's not
gonna play Monday night by the way if he
doesn't play because he's suspended it
would cost him eight hundred sixty
thousand dollars and the team can fire
suspend him up to four games to conduct
detrimental he could have made a 2.4
million dollar punt of the football and
threat to physically yeah two points and
we don't know so terrible about I think
it's 2.4 million I think I'm writing
that right or 2.6 I'm so terrible at
math yeah what is that four times it's
crazy it's crazy talk right there one
pets it's something yeah
three inch chain um but we don't know if
that's gonna happen right it's can't you
sit him down Monday and Pam what it
doesn't give him a paid absence no
that's to go back to like like Tio's we
need Co situation when he was in uh
Philly they did something would I do
with him they uh three point four
million yeah yeah no but what they did
know is the Keshawn is what Ratanak
remember the Bucks just did Gruden was
Keyshawn home for the rest of the year
and I think for like six games and then
they came up and had collective
bargaining Lee when you can't do that
anymore the max is for games walking for
conduct detrimental and then teo got
sent home by the eagles to wrap up his
career and where he did and Drew
Rosenhaus is he's been there and done
that he was his agent there too you know
what you asked a question about like
what could be done yes sir how could
this be
yes you know I guess resolved that would
take some serious looking inside and
saying some pride it we have to be
swallowed swallowed a lot of it and I
don't know if that's me saying that
before you came on that you know he's
got someone has to sit him down again
we're not fully well-versed on
everything it just sounds again based on
what he posted on Instagram yesterday
how that led to a confrontation with his
general manager who he threatened
verbally and punting a football saying
fined me for this and now he's not at
the facility today chef ders reporting
they're planning on suspending him
putting him at all together it is simple
to basically say someone asked to sit
him down and say this behavior that got
you out of Pittsburgh and got you paid
is now viewed league-wide as
self-destructive whether you feel you're
being self-destructive or not it is
self-destructive it's now gonna cost you
eight hundred sixty thousand dollars I
don't think we can get that back because
you threatened your giotto I think what
we can do is make a case that they can't
void all your guarantees because of it
that you missed one practice one
walkthrough and threaten your GM all
that together I don't know if that's
gonna wash to wipe away thirty million
in guarantees but you're helping them
stay to Casey or Antonio
and if you want to get paid you better
go back you better apologize to mike
Mayock and you just go ball out no I
mean you have to work here who's gonna
pay him this money again people get shot
not not not for this not on the hook for
that amount of money yeah right and I'm
surprised we because we now you're
talking you know language that I think
everybody understands dollars and for a
guy that it seems like everything he
does there's a calculated move or
positioning to to make money whether
it's Facebook live where there's this
helmet deal which got the new deal now
and they sit there and think then you're
gonna now jeopardize you know game
checks yeah doesn't make sense to me no
like that
the money is talking it's a it's
actually screaming at the top of its
list right now
yes but who was that person though it's
gotta be drew Rosenhaus yeah who else
could it be I mean IIIi don't know his
personal life and who could be the one
who sit him down
could it be an old coach could it be I
don't know to reach because it seems
like something needs to be but don't you
think if that person was in his life
that that person would have talked to
him already a year a year to ago I'm
just I don't come started out there like
to me that I know and maybe there was a
guy or you know a woman in his life
who-who did do that and I've seen it
happen where as some people ascend to a
certain level it happens where they'd
become or they're not listening anymore
yes they just there's just this big kind
of monster and its own you know kind of
conglomerate and he's not I don't know
if he's if he if anybody can catch his
ear at this point jus rosenhouse might
be the only person but I don't you think
he would have had a conversation oh I
don't know about that I mean because we
saw how you know he was backing him on
the helmet thing yeah as opposed to
saying come on Antonio like let's let's
figure this out I'll get you a deal for
a new helmet but let's let's just go
yeah I don't know it sounds like there's
been a lot of enabling going on but I
again this is a lot of you know outside
looking in dime-store psychoanalysis
that you know that's I don't know
how accurate it very mean right right I
mean I think we all did most people
having that reaction right now and again
like you said we don't it's an entire
I'm not trying to pile on I'm not trying
to just come down on them for this but
this is this it's just the thing that
continues to happen you see it right you
can't blame this on Big Ben no no I was
I'm curious to get his thoughts across
let's get Big Ben alright now go Ben
from Pittsburgh you're on the Rich Eisen
show that's an odd phone number phone
call do I have you do I have this man to
the rest of the hour
do I cuz I know you got to go across the
way okay very good you let's take a
break then come back and talk about the
rest of the the rest of the the the
league and then and hit a little bit
more on the NFL Sunday Ticket that
you're here to talk about I just want to
let you know the UEFA Champions League
group stage kicks off September 17th
stream every game on matchday one in the
entire 2019 2020 UEFA Champions League
season only on be our life will talk
Sunday Ticket and the rest of the
National Football League season that
kicks off tonight with pro Football Hall
of Famer Terrell Davis he'll take us
home when we come back I'll get back to
the Rich Eisen show we haven't talked
much baseball cuz obviously football
starts tonight and man Tonio Browns
gotten it appears to be suspended we'll
see what happens there Gerald Avis in
studio right here I do want to mention
how a Capital One best life player of
the week is the New York Mets Pete
Alonzo who it is forty fifth home run of
the season in beating the Nats last
night no Mets player has ever led major
league baseball on home runs in a single
season as he does right now no rookie
has ever held a major league baseball
lead in home runs out right in a single
season he is your best life Player of
the Week and it's brought to you by
Capital One the way you can open a
checking or savings account of no fees
no minimums and there's Capital One
cafes when you want to see somebody in
person the Capital One best life player
of the week Kiko Alonso What's in you of
Pete Alonso what's in your wallet Kiko
Alonso is also because he got out of
Miami Canada trade he's now at the
Saints so basically made that Maria
Conchita Alonso is having
wherever she might be that's all that's
all the Alonso I've got that's all Maya
that's all my Alonso's they've got let's
go to what great more take a phone call
let's go who's on a break in South
Carolina let's take a phone call what's
up Greg you're Alma Terrell Davis sir
I'm doing great how you doing I'm great
I'm not able to you know see you in
person but I want to say you had a
historic career and I'm very happy well
thank you I appreciate that you got a
question for me right into it two things
one of the biggest things and maybe
YouTube Sorrell I'm a Giants fan and you
know every year everything says oh maybe
that's this year give me a team nobody's
looking at that can come out of no
that's a good question Chet it's a good
question and call Craig yeah that's
that's a good question and I've been
saying this team all offseason and it to
me it's the Buccaneers man whoa yeah
Aryans and Jameis you like that mix I do
i do I just think last show knowing that
you have Todd Bowles who is heading up
that defense and member lasted
defensively they were horrible and if
you can get that defense and you know to
just finish somewhere middle to packet
they're in a division yeah the Saints
are there
you think Carolina's gonna be better
Atlanta is probably gonna be better but
Tampa's just seemed like a team that
they had the makings of a really good
office last year and last time I checked
they be able to dolphins you got a
chance in this league and Jameis just
got a headache arm and it's got
everything as a guide everybody's gone
you know Zeus Aryans always been able to
get that get a quarterback to to perform
and play well and Ben Carson Andrew Luck
yeah yes so three so that's so that's
why I say that's the team for me would
be Tampa up and so yeah that's that's my
kind of under the radar squad is the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers how you feel about
that one I don't I I can't disagree with
that by the way that's the leat that's
the most mealy-mouthed way to agree with
somebody it was funny the other reason
to riches every year there's a team that
goes from worst to first that's true
well to first now you're gonna choose
that one is it worse to first whoa give
you another one in a in a division give
me another one look at all the teams in
the division last year
that was the I'm not getting this
Jacksonville's the one we were talking
about it in the in the commercial break
as you were taking a look at it because
of the end NFL Sunday Ticket Sunday max
a preview this weekend basically week
one is on the house for DirecTV
customers this Sunday enjoy access to
every live out-of-market game the four
and eight game mix channels and channel
701 702 the redzone channel DirecTV
fantasy zone channel it's the 100 season
as we all know in the National Football
League to order Sunday Ticket and
continue to get access to every live out
of market Sunday game this season after
this Sunday go to DIRECTV dot-com / NFL
or call 1-800 get sports to order today
you took a look at the list right this
and we're like Chiefs of Jaguars now
that's a sneaky week one game that is
really that's why I'm saying the Jaguars
would Nick Foles they're healthy again
that they got John Dee filippo as their
OC he was the QB coach when foals went
on that magical run in Philadelphia
they're up front hopefully more healthy
for net appears to be 20 pounds lighter
right he seems to be really up and Jalen
Ramsey on the backend of a defense
that's got what they got up front in
gaga josh josh class campbell yeah
that's my candidate from works at first
especially yeah although I think the
Colts are gonna be just fine what do you
think yeah that's uh that's a tough one
you know I know Jacoby Brissette was
there and really got all the first team
reps in midair you know all last year
and that's just a hard that's a tough
one to swallow I mean like you to have
your starting quarterback just retire
right before the season and I don't it's
not that I don't blame him because I
understand going through that mentally
for three years of trying to rehab but
just did the shock that I can have to
your squad you know expecting him to
come back and then he doesn't come back
so are the coats I mean I don't think
I'll be the same team so I can't say
that I feel strongly about the Colts now
as I did before so in the couple minutes
we have left here the Broncos what are
they gonna look like this year what do
you think give me something better than
last year okay
this is where they're improving they've
improved off on the offensive line they
brought in the you know Mike Munchak
who's a really good offensive line coach
right so they're so I think they're good
they got you on James they brought it
from the Dolphins this is the right
tackle in this defense and dangerous
hand it's gonna be nab solutely so you
know the defense is gonna be a top 5
defense that's that's you can count on
that
the run game is gonna be really really
good with Lindsay and Royce Freeman I
think Flacco was surrounded by all this
no a fan it's a tight and they they
draft in the first round a higher man
you know but but if they get but I know
he's got his issues but right
they have tight ends that I believe
that's kind of suit Joe Flacco and that
offers a lot of boots mixed directions
put him on a roll and run and Flacco I
believe it's gonna be a Reno it's gonna
be solid he's gonna be solid
well that is though by the way if that
is the most backhanded compliment
adjectives and the history here is solid
that is you can win with solid you can
win with solid by the way you can win
with solid that is oddly enough I this
is just a Rich Eisen show exclusive we
just saw its breaking news the 2019
Denver Broncos motto is win with solid
that's what Fangio is gonna go out there
you guys first game is head coach I know
Tonio Browns not out there but you know
we are we are solid that's right solid
exactly how does that sound that sounds
great to me let's go win let's go let's
go we're opaque good solid you put Elway
on sodium pentathol he thinks what does
he say about Flacco put him on sodium
pentathol he loves whacko why wouldn't
he alright I got I got 40 seconds left
your Super Bowl 54 prediction is
drilling it my prediction I've been
saying
I'm going with the man I don't wanna say
this team but I think the Chiefs who
might might make it this year
okay and and I'm out of the NFC drumroll
plays but room okay
my I'm gonna I'm gonna get screen a
little bit here I'm going to Vikings
Vikings throwdown
okay in this one you like that you know
what I think that is solid you like a
solid pick
I think cousins in the Super Bowl that
is solid and it's good for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app